ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen zum
ersten Mal hat die AFD eine politische
Machtposition erreicht es ist zwar nur
eine kommunale Spitzenposition nämlich
ein Landratsposten aber viele fragen
sich jetzt ist das erst der Anfang und
welche Macht hat ein afd-landrat
überhaupt wir hätten gerne selbst mit
ihm darüber gesprochen mit Robert
Sesselmann der für die AFD in Sonneberg
in Thüringen die Wahl gewonnen hat er
hat uns aber aus Termin Gründen abgesagt
also sprechen wir mit unseren
Korrespondenten in Berlin und in
Thüringen unserer Studioleiterin dort
vor Ort und mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Benjamin Höhne
und wir freuen uns natürlich auf eure
und Ihre Fragen und Kommentare was
haltet ihr davon dass ein afd-mann jetzt
Landrat ist was glaubt ihr welche macht
kann er dort ausüben und warum haben so
viele Menschen ihnen gewählt es gibt auf
jeden Fall schon heute sehr viele
Reaktionen auf diese Wahl und Florian
kortschik fast sie zusammen
Sonneberg am Morgen für einige hier ist
die Wahl eine Abrechnung mit der
Bundespolitik andere sind schockiert
das ist heute früh das heißeste Thema
und ja schwierig
ich finde es etwas peinlich für
Sonneberg ich muss ich echt auch muss
ich was ändern
mir bezahlen für alle wir bezahlen für
die Ukraine es kommt die Ausländer haben
wir bezahlen für alle und alles und für
unsere Leute ist kein Geld da also ich
bin erschüttert
weil rechts Partei kann man nicht wählen
aufgrund der ganzen geschichtlichen
Situation die man ja schon durch hatten
Jubel bei der AFD am Abend als das
Wahlergebnis bekannt wird erstmals
gewinnt die Partei einen kommunalen
Amtssitz der Landkreis Sonneberg
schreibt Geschichte
die AFD ist nunmehr als Volkspartei hier
im Kommunalbereich in Thüringen und auch
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
angekommen im ZDF Morgenmagazin spricht
der Bundesvorsitzende der Linken von
einem Alarmsignal für die Demokratie
wenn Vertreter einer Partei die
offenkundig antidemokratisch sei in
offizielle Ämter gewählt werden von
daher müssen wir jetzt ganz genau
darüber nachdenken wie man auch die
Erfahrung der ostdeutschen jetzt wieder
so in die politische Debatte einspeisen
kann dass sie sich eben nicht frustriert
der AFD zu werden sondern demokratischen
Parteien in Sonneberg müssen sich jetzt
Robert Sesselmann und die AFD beweisen
und an ihren Wahlversprechen messen
lassen
Melanie Haack ist unsere Studioleiterin
in Thüringen und jetzt vor Ort in
Sonneberg Melanie wir haben viele
Reaktionen jetzt schon im Stück gesehen
welche Gespräche hast du heute morgen
dort geführt
ja die Gespräche sind ganz ähnlich und
das sind auch die Reaktionen auf das
Ergebnis und ähnlich war es auch in den
ganzen letzten Wochen in denen wir hier
in Sonneberg und im gesamten Landkreis
unterwegs waren was die Menschen
umtreibt das ist nicht mit einer Antwort
zu beschreiben es sind
Ängste es sind Abstiegsängste die die
Menschen haben den Wohlstand den man
sich hier seit der Wende in den letzten
30 Jahren geschaffen hat die Angst ist
da dass davon weniger übrig bleibt und
das im Portemonnaie und das Thema Geld
scheint bei vielen eben auch eine große
Rolle zu spielen und hinzu kommt dann
die Unzufriedenheit und das mengt sich
dann hier zusammen in Frust der ja auch
schon zu corona-zeiten auf die Straße
getragen wurde und die Menschen das
hören wir immer wieder sagen ja die da
oben und meinen damit die Bundespolitik
vor allen Dingen und sie beschreiben
hier immer sie fühlen sich gegängelt mit
dem Streit um die Heizung das
heizungsgesetz Mann der Streit innerhalb
der Ampelkoalition und auch das Thema
Flüchtlinge ist ein Thema dass die
Menschen hier umtreibt und man muss dazu
sagen dieser Landkreis ist ländlich
geprägt hier in Südthüringen und
natürlich sind die Landesregierungen
Erfurt und die Bundesregierung in Berlin
für die Menschen hier geführt sehr weit
weg wir sind hier im Thüringer Wald und
eine Rolle spielt auch dass viele
Menschen älter sind es sind natürlich
auch viele abgewandert in vielen
kleineren Orten und Dörfern ist das zu
spüren dass vor allem ältere Menschen
übrig geblieben sind ich sehe hier in
den Chat schon viele Fragen und
Kommentare und eine kommt von einem Toni
618 der fragt was erwarten denn die
Wähler von Herrn Sesselmann was soll in
Zukunft anders laufen
ja das ist eine schwierige Frage die man
so ein bisschen umfassen dann noch mal
beantwortet worden muss Herr Sesselmann
hat ja mit bundespolitischen Themen
Wahlkampf gemacht das sind Themen die
ein Landrat größtenteils überhaupt nicht
umsetzen kann und die Menschen haben mir
immer gesagt wir wollen ein Signal
setzen im Grunde sammelt sich dieser
Frust den ich gerade beschrieben habe
kanalisierte sich mit dieser Wahl und
viele sagen eben ja ich habe ein Zeichen
gesetzt jetzt ist er da und jetzt muss
er sich beweisen und wir hatten damit
die Chance ein Signal setzen zu können
mit dieser Wahl
das heißt aber konkret erwarten von ihm
an Änderungsmöglichkeiten lass uns
damals sprechen welchen
Gestaltungsspielraum man denn als
Landrat hat wir haben mal eine Grafik
vorbereitet und zu gucken was sind die
Aufgaben und die Möglichkeiten eines
Landrats in Thüringen schauen wir uns an
Melanie der Landrat ist der oberste
Beamte seines Landkreises das heißt er
ist auch Chef der Kreisverwaltung
gewählt wird er für 6 Jahre
er setzt die Beschlüsse um die im
Kreistag getroffen werden hier ist aber
in Thüringen nicht die AFD die stärkste
Kraft sondern die CDU der Landrat
vertritt seinen Landkreis nach außen und
nach innen hat also vor allem eine
repräsentative Rolle zum Beispiel bei
Feuerwehrfesten oder bei
Einweihungsfeiern und wenn wir jetzt mal
auf die Macht gucken da gibt's schon
gewisse Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten als
Vorgesetzter der Beamten hat er das
letzte Wort bei verschiedenen
Stellenbesetzungen und er hat in der
Verwaltung auch Einfluss auf
Baugenehmigung zum Beispiel und im
Kreistag kann er dafür sorgen dass
Themen gesetzt werden wie z.B die
flüchtlingsunterbringung dass sowas auf
die Tagesordnung kommt also man kann
jetzt nicht sagen Melanie das ist
irgendwie nur so ein großes August der
repräsentative Aufgaben macht hat
sondern er kann schon in gewisser Weise
Macht ausüben
genau das kann er ist aber Exekutive und
das heißt er muss auch Gesetze verfolgen
also Gesetze befolgen und auch ausführen
er hat jetzt nicht freie Hand
grundlegende Dinge zu ändern
grundsätzlich ist ein Landrat ja auch
zuständig fürs Kita Personal und ist ja
gerade auch angesprochen werden worden
für die Sanierung von Gebäuden und
Straßen aber er ist nicht ganz allein
und man muss auch sagen als Landrat muss
er auch Investoren anlocken also er muss
auch Fachkräfte hier in die Region
bringen die händeringend auch Fachkräfte
angewiesen ist und natürlich ist die
Frage wenn wir jetzt aufs Landratsamt
schauen ähm wie die jetzt auch damit
umgehen und wie man da zusammenarbeitet
aber er hat nicht die Möglichkeit jetzt
einfach Gesetze zu ändern oder Dinge
durchzusetzen die die Mehrheit nicht
durchsetzen möchte also soweit geht sein
Gestaltungsspielraum nicht
darf ich Dinge genau
da wollte ich gerade nachfragen weil das
hier auch ganz viele interess iert einer
fragt erwarten die Wähler jetzt
Abschiebungen von der AFD
ja also das ist nicht so einfach möglich
es gibt ja einen Verteilschlüssel und
jeder Landkreis bekommt eine bestimmte
Zahl an Flüchtlingen zugeteilt und der
Landrat ist dann dafür zuständig diese
Flüchtlinge im Landkreis auf die Region
zu verteilen also das ist nicht so
einfach möglich in der AFD hieß es man
wolle gucken ob man dann Geldleistung
zur Sachleistungen ändern könnte ja um
da irgendwie einen Zeichen zu setzen was
da konkret möglich ist das können wir
jetzt noch nicht wirklich absehen wieder
der Gestaltungsspielraum ist aber
tatsächlich ist es einem Landrat nicht
möglich zu sagen wir nehmen die
Flüchtlinge jetzt nicht die hier auf den
Landkreis verteilt werden
ich gucke hier gerade noch mal in die
Chats und fass mal so ein bisschen
zusammen es gibt viel Kommentare pro AFD
viel Kommentare contra AFD ähm
Hans-jürgen Frick z.B schreibt endlich
passiert was Unverschämtheit was diese
Regierung dem Land zumutet und ein
anderer User namens die felius schreibt
wer sich mit der AFD und deren Programm
beschäftigt der merkt schnell dass diese
keinesfalls selber ist keine
Perspektiven und Plänen nur Hass und
möglichst viel Geld denen in die Tasche
stecken das also mal zwei beispielhafte
Kommentare hier aus den Chats Melanie
lass uns noch drüber sprechen wie die
Politik jetzt vor Ort damit umgeht wie
reagieren denn jetzt die anderen
Parteien auf dieses Ergebnis
ja und das ist eine spannende und
gleichzeitig auch wichtige Frage das
merken wir hier auch immer wenn wir im
Landkreis unterwegs sind die anderen
Parteien linke SPD Grüne und auch die
FDP hatten ja eine Wahlempfehlung für
den CDU-Kandidaten gegeben also sie
hatten sich zusammengeschlossen und
größtenteils diese Wahlempfehlung
gegeben die Frage ist aber was heißt es
langfristig wir waren jetzt am Samstag
habe ich in dem kleinen Ort Steinach
gedreht und habe dort mit vielen
Menschen gesprochen der hier auch zu
diesem Landkreis gehört dort ist der
Bürgermeister parteilos seit 2006 gibt
es ihn und die Beschreibung ist dort
auch dass die Parteien auch immer
weniger vor Ort und verankert sind man
muss bedenken in Ostdeutschland ist
diese langfristige parteienbindung diese
Parteimitgliedschaft diese festen
Strukturen nie so gewachsen gewesen wie
in den alten Bundesländern da galt es
auch viel aufzubauen und in Steinach zum
Beispiel sagte mir der Bürgermeister na
ja die Menschen sind alt viele sterben
weg und damit nimmt auch die Zahl der
Mitglieder in den Parteien ab und die
Parteien selbst haben auch ein
Personalproblem weil es auch schwieriger
wird zum einen Menschen zu motivieren
Politik mit anzugehen und zu gestalten
und gerade das Thema gestalten ist ein
ganz wichtiges Thema wo der
Bürgermeister sagte das eine ist die
Verantwortung der Parteien die sich
wieder stärker verankern muss zum
Beispiel ganz klassisch wenn wir hier
hinten in Sonneberg in der Stadt gucken
die einen sagen ich muss mein Parteibüro
hier in der Mitte haben viele können
sich das nicht leisten haben das nicht
und damit sind Parteien auch allein von
der Personalstärke und der Präsenz
weniger vor Ort dass das was die
Menschen dann noch immer sagen ja wo
sind die denn auf der Straße wo merke
ich sie denn das ist eine große
Herausforderung für die Parteien und Sie
müssen sich ja auch gegenseitig
voneinander abgrenzen sicherlich war das
jetzt für die Parteien selbst
nachvollziehbar sich da zusammen zu
schließen aber auf lange Sicht müssen
Sie natürlich eigene Rezepte Konzepte
finden um die Menschen wieder
zurückzuholen und was der Bürgermeister
mir in Steinach auch sagte naja meckern
ist das eine er sagt aber auch
demokratie heißt mitmachen und gestalten
nicht nur durch die Politik sondern auch
durch die Bürger selbst das heißt
Zivilgesellschaft stärken in den
Vereinen aktiv sein und so weiter also
das ist eine Aufgabe die die Parteien
und die Bürger selbst auch lösen müssen
vielen Dank Melanie Haack unsere
Studioleiterin in Thüringen das wird ein
interessantes Thema bleiben denn ihr
habt ja auch Landtagswahlen dann im
nächsten Jahr vielen Dank dass du uns
diese Einblicke genau Sonneberg
mitgebracht hast danke schön
und wir schauen jetzt mal darauf welche
Auswirkungen das denn in Berlin hat
dieses Wahlergebnis und blicken da mal
auf den Twitter Account von Alice Weidel
der Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
AFD die hat getwittert gratulation nach
Sonneberg wir sind Landrat die AFD also
in Feierlaune auch in Berlin
robert-sesselmann hat Geschichte
geschrieben das ist erst der Anfang
schreibt Alice Weidel das ist die
Grundlage für mein Gespräch mit unserer
Korrespondentin im Hauptstadtstudio
nämlich mit Nicole Dieckmann Nicole wir
haben es gesehen die AFD feiert auf
Twitter wie sind denn sonst die
Reaktionen in der Bundeshauptstadt ja es
gab etliche Reaktionen liebe Christina
wir haben ja eben schon Martin gesehen
der heute morgen hier im ZDF
Morgenmagazin zu Gast war und sie schon
geäußert hat und es gab auch noch
weitere lass uns doch mal reinhören
wir wollen natürlich die nächsten
Landratswahlen genauso erfolgreich
gestalten das sind beginnen ganz klar
sagen es ist jetzt irgend soll jetzt
auch nicht außergewöhnliches sein es ist
eine Kommunalwahl wir haben immer gesagt
wir wollen kommunalgestalten wir wollen
im Interesse der bürgerpolitik machen
und wir beginnen hier in Sonneberg und
es wird weitere Wahlkreise geben wo wir
beweisen können dass wir Politik machen
können für die Interessen und deswegen
ist das heute erst der Anfang ja das ist
ein politisches Wetterleuchten das heute
hier die Sonneberger vom Rennsteig
ausgesendet haben in die Republik und
wir sind ja in einer sehr positiven
Dynamik als AFD bundesweit natürlich
schon seit einigen Monaten und ich
glaube dass diese positive Dynamik durch
diesen diesen diesen wichtigen Sieg noch
mal katalysiert werden kann noch mal
beschleunigt werden kann sich noch mal
weiter auf potenzieren kann und dann
bereiten uns schon auf die
Landtagswahlen im Osten vor wo dann
wirklich ein politisches Erdbeben
erzeugt werden könnte ja wenn es ist
natürlich ein Alarmsignal für die
Demokratie das mittlerweile Vertreter
einer Partei die offenkundig
antidemokratisch ist die die Demokratie
für te Demokratie zerstören will in
offizielle Ämter gewählt werden wir
jetzt gerade im Kreis Sonneberg von
daher müssen jetzt ganz genau darüber
nachdenken wie man Demokratie stärken
kann an dieser Stelle und wie man vor
allem und das ist ja in Ostdeutschland
in Thüringen Sonneberg wie man auch die
Erfahrung der ostdeutschen jetzt wieder
so in die politische Debatte einspeisen
kann dass sie sich eben nicht frustriert
der AFD zu werden sondern demokratischen
Parteien
tja also soweit die Reaktionen einmal
von der Linkspartei und dann natürlich
auch von den beiden
afd-mitgliedern bleiben wir erstmal bei
der AFD was machen die jetzt mit diesem
Sieg was machen Sie darauf
es ist natürlich relativ einfach björn
höcke hat das ja gerade auch schon
angedeutet in dieser kompletten
Gemengelage für die AFD das als
Rückenwind zu begreifen denn gestern ja
das ist aus Sicht der AFD tatsächlich
ein historischer Tag
kommunalpolitik ist das worauf die AFD
guckt worauf sie schielt und wo sie
gestern eben ihren ersten großen Erfolg
feiern konnte
Kommunalpolitik so die Hoffnung hilft
dabei immer weiter normalisiert zu
werden die berühmte Brandmauer die die
anderen Parteien zu ihr noch hochziehen
ganz vorne weg die Unionsparteien die
CDU unter Friedrich Merz er betont das
immer wieder Stück für Stück einzureißen
nämlich durch das narrativ das entstehen
soll mit den kann man doch ganz gut
zusammenarbeiten schaut wie gut das
funktioniert und unter jetzt konkret
Leitung eines AFD landrattes und so will
man sich Stück für Stück weiter
vorarbeiten in dem Wunsch irgendwann
dann tatsächlich für Koalition
in Frage zu kommen aus Sicht der anderen
Parteien das heißt das soll erst der
Anfang sein die Freude ist riesig
innerhalb der AFD das heißt man wird
jetzt auch beobachten können dass die
AFD von ihrer Oppositionspolitik die sie
immer gemacht hat fundamental dagegen zu
sein jetzt versuchen wir zunehmend
konstruktiver zu wirken um dann auch
macht Verantwortung
perspektivisch übernehmen zu können oder
was werden wir da jetzt erleben das
würde ich erstmal ausschließen denn was
ja auch in der Familie gerade
angesprochenen Gemengelage was da auch
zugehört sind die sonntagsfragen der
vergangenen Wochen die AFD knackt in den
Umfragen einen Rekord nach dem anderen
hat nie zuvor da gewesene Werte diese
erzielt und das ist Nicole entschuldige
lass uns kurz gemeinsam drauf gucken die
Zahlen die du anspricht haben wir hier
nämlich gerade vorliegen nur damit man
es auch noch mal so richtig vor Augen
hat wir haben ja diese Woche kein ZDF
Politbarometer aber die Kollegen von der
AFD haben hier die Sonntagsfrage
gestellt der Deutschland Trend von 23.06
das sind die neuesten Zahlen und da
sehen wir dass die AFD mit 19 Prozent
jetzt an Platz 2 liegt und zwar hinter
der CDU die käme auf 29 Prozent wenn am
nächsten Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre und
dann erst auf Platz drei kommt die SPD
mit 17 Prozent hier sehen wir es nochmal
Nicole bitte ja danke ja super sehr
anschaulich genau das ist jetzt die
jüngste Umfrage von vielen in denen die
AFD wie gesagt ein Rekord knackt und das
tut sie tatsächlich in Form einer aus
Prinzip dagegen Politik die sie die
vergangenen Monate wie auch schon die
Jahre zuvor seit ihrem Bestehen vertritt
ähm es wäre aus Sicht der AFD also
unlogisch jetzt plötzlich konstruktiv
mitzuarbeiten
Melanie Haack hat das ja gerade auch
noch mal sehr anschaulich beschrieben
mit welchen Themen der
Landratskandidat und jetzt eben auch
Gewinner der Wahl auf welche Themen der
gesetzt hat das waren keine Themen die
für Landrat eine Rolle spielen sondern
das waren die Themen auf die die AFD
auch im Bund setzt und sei es sein es
Sanktionen gegen Russland sei es die
Energiewende sei es die Europolitik die
AFD ist so schreiben es auch viele
Kommentatoren die dagegenpartei dabei
wird es aus meiner Sicht auch bleiben
ihr schreibt auch in diese Richtung
Claudia Stecher über Facebook blöd dass
die Versprechen von Sesselmann nicht in
seinem entscheidungsspektrum liegen als
Landrat also die Frage der Kompetenz
muss man sich hier wirklich ganz genau
angucken aber man sieht ja auch zum
Beispiel dass der Gegenkandidat von der
CDU gesagt hat wir hatten überhaupt
keine Chance denn die in Berlin also
auch der hat mit dem Finger auf Berlin
gezeigt haben uns einfach überhaupt
keine andere Chance gelassen was machen
denn jetzt die anderen Parteien in
Berlin damit
ja also man muss sagen der
Herausforderer von Robert Sesselmann war
ein CDU man jetzt in der Stichwahl und
der führt damit konsequent das fort was
im Moment ich würde mal sagen die
Strategie das mit dem Finger aufeinander
zeigen darstellt es gibt da wenige
Ausnahmen aber wenn man allein heute mal
schaut was da aus den anderen Parteien
kam Mario Czaja
CDU-Generalsekretär macht die Ampel im
Bund verantwortlich jetzt auch für
dieses afd-ergebnis in Sonneberg katrin
Göring-Eckardt von den Grünen und
Vizepräsidentin im Bundestag wiederum
sagt die CDU stellt ein großes Problem
da zettelt einen Kulturkampf an das
spielt ausschließlich der AFD in die
Hände Stefan weil Ministerpräsident in
Niedersachsen und SPD-Politiker wiederum
sagt es gibt einen großen Unterschied
zwischen Ost und West also ähm es gibt
inzwischen auch die ersten
selbstkritischen Töne aus dem Parteien
aber im Großen und Ganzen versucht man
den anderen quasi die Verantwortung für
den Erfolg der AFD in die Schuhe zu
schieben und das kommt überhaupt nicht
gut an auch nicht hier in den Chat hier
schreibt jemand namens gell red warum
versucht man nicht besser die Wähler der
AFD abzuholen es ist frustrierend keine
politischen Reflexionen zu solchen
Wahlen zu sehen ja die Frage ist wie
holt man sie ab das ist ja eine
Gretchenfrage seit mehreren Jahren seit
zehn Jahren die die AFD jetzt existiert
setzt man darauf ihr wording zu
übernehmen versucht man ihre Politik
quasi nicht zu kopieren aber die Themen
zu besetzen die die AFD besetzt und ein
bisschen schärfer verbal vielleicht auch
an der rechten Kante zu surfen das ist
ja ein Versuch den Markus Söder der
jetzt wieder zur Wahl steht in Bayern
als Ministerpräsident CSU vor ein paar
Jahren schon mal versucht hat das ist
eine Strategie die man jetzt auch mit
unter Friedrich Merz nachsagt wir
erinnern uns der Auftritt von Claudia
Pechstein vor gut einer Woche auf einer
CDU Veranstaltung wird als ein solcher
Versuch gewerte die März anschließend
als brillant bezeichnet hat diese Rede
war schwer umstritten nicht nur bei
Claudia Pechstein eine Polizeiuniform
getragen hat sondern auch wegen der
Inhalt ihrer Rede die Frage ist ob das
wirklich diese Strategie ist ob die
verfängt die Frage ist tatsächlich wäre
es sinnvoller für die Ampel weniger auch
nach außen zu streiten besser zu
kommunizieren generell es gibt so sieht
es im Moment ja stark aus kein Rezept
jedenfalls keins das bisher angewendet
worden wäre
vielen Dank Nicole Diekmann bis hierhin
zu diesem Thema heute nach Berlin und
wir reden darüber hier im Stream weiter
ich gucke noch mal in die Kommentare und
möchte einen Kommentar aufgreifen da
schreibt nämlich jemand dieses Ergebnis
wird stark instrumentalisiert werden um
in weiteren Kreisen Stimmen zu sammeln
was können andere Parteien tun um
zukünftig dagegen zu halten und da gibt
es einen interessanten Punkt nämlich das
was wir gerade gesehen haben dass alle
anderen Parteien dazu aufrufen den AFD
gegen Kandidaten zu wählen dass es in
diesem Fall passiert und es hat am Ende
aber nicht funktioniert denn der
afd-kandidat hat trotzdem die Mehrheit
bekommen und dieses gemeinsam sich gegen
die AFD stellen was die Wahlempfehlung
angeht das ist durchaus umstritten der
ehemalige Fraktionsvorsitzende der CDU
in Thüringen Mike Mohring hat sich dazu
geäußert
wie kommt das bei den Wählern an wenn
alle anderen sich wie ihre eigene
inhaltlichen Programmatiken zurücknehmen
nur um die Partei AFD zu verhindern ich
glaube auf Dauer ist das ein schwieriger
Prozess der nicht aufgehen wird
auf Dauer ein schwieriger Prozess der
nicht aufgehen wird das ist die Frage an
den Politikwissenschaftler Professor
Benjamin Höhne er kommt selbst aus
Wittenberg in Sachsen-Anhalt und lehrt
jetzt an der Westfälischen
Wilhelms-Universität in Münster schön
dass Sie dabei sind Herr Professor Höhne
Steinberg sehen Sie das genauso kritisch
wie Herr Mohring dieses sich verbünden
verschiedener Parteien die ja ganz
unterschiedliche Ausrichtungen haben
ganz unterschiedliche Themen um einen
afd-kandidaten zu verhindern
ja wenn wir jetzt diese Äußerung von der
Mohring sehen dann muss man ja auch
sehen dass er ziemlich hin und her
laviert hat in Thüringen was die
Position der CDU anbelangt zur AFD aber
auch zum Ministerpräsidenten der von der
Linkspartei kommt ich glaube schon dass
dieser Krone Sanitär oder die Brandmauer
einige geeignete Strategie gibt ist um
mit den rechtspopulistischen bis
rechtsextremen Mitgliedern der AFD
umzugehen die hat aber natürlich auch
eine kernseite sie spielt in gewisser
Weise der AFD auch in die Hände weil sie
sich dann wieder vor ihre eigenen
Klientel hinstellen kann und
argumentieren kann sieht mal die
etablierten Parteien oder wie sie sagen
die Altparteien die versuchen uns
auszuschließen es sollte nicht nur der
CDU Schwerpunkt überlassen sein diese
Brandauer einzuziehen sondern es sollte
eine gemeinsame Sache aller Parteien
sein die sie zum Pluralismus bekennen
und es sollte auch darüber nachgedacht
werden die Medien immer die richtige
Strategie gegenüber der AFD
dann lassen Sie uns noch mal auf dieses
Beispiel jetzt tatsächlich gucken hier
gibt es unter anderem Zuspruch von einem
User der schreibt ich denke die AFD hat
die Chance verdient das glauben sie wird
die AFD jetzt mit dieser wenn auch
beschränkten aber dann doch im
kommunalen durchaus bestehenden
Machtpositionen anfangen
das ist schon im Grunde ein
schockierendes Ereignis gewesen gestern
für das Parteiensystem für die deutsche
Demokratie mit der glaube ich nur wenige
gerechnet hätten weil sich in der
Vergangenheit ja gezeigt hat dass doch
immer noch eine Mehrheit ähm der anderen
Parteien gegen die AFD zustande zu
bringen war bei den ähm Landtagswahlen
in der jüngeren Vergangenheit also diese
Gewissheit ist damit weg und dieser
Erfolg den die AFD dafür sich
reklamieren kann in Sonneberg der trägt
weit zu ihrer Normalisierung oder
mainstreamisierung Strategie sie möchte
also als normale Partei anerkannt werden
man wird mit ihren in Sonneberg irgendwo
zusammenarbeiten müssen weil er
sozusagen ist keine AFD Mehrheit im
Kreistag gibt also da wird es dann
sozusagen
institutionelle Kooperationen geben
müssen und das reizt sich aus Sicht der
AFD gut eben in ihre Normalisierung
Strategie ein
wenn wir auf die Wahlbeteiligung schauen
dann sehen wir dass sie gerade mal bei
58 Prozent liegt das ist ja auch wenn es
nur in Anführungszeichen eine
Landratswahl war aber es ging ja auch um
viel nicht wirklich viel sind nur nicht
die Rechten zu stark sondern auch der
Wille der anderen zu schwach an dieser
Stelle die Demokratie zu verteidigen
das muss man ein Stück weit in Relation
setzen und da sind diese fast 60%
Wahlbeteiligung bei einer für sich
stehenden Landratswahl die nicht
verbunden war mit einer Landtagswahl
oder einer anderen Wahl sind doch schon
ein eher gutes Ergebnis also im Schnitt
sind solche waren sie weniger Resonanz
in der Wählerin schafft das muss man
erstmal rausstellen und wenn sie die
Zahlen anschauen dann sehen wir dass die
AFD noch mal mobilisieren konnte und
meines Erachtens nach steht das auch ein
Stück weit dafür für eine zu wenig
resiliente Zivilgesellschaft die sich
gegenüber dem Rechtsextremismus
positionieren kann steht für die dünne
Personaldecke der anderen Parteien und
genau in dieses Loch oder diese Lücke
versucht die AFD mit ihrer
kommunalpolitischen Strategie auch
einzudringen also wir sehen das ja auch
an anderen Orten dass sie
Landtagsabgeordnete nominiert die auf
kommunaler Ebene für Spitzenämter
antreten und dabei sozusagen aufgrund
dieser viel viel dünner aufgestellten
Zivilgesellschaft im Osten ist leichter
hat dann auch dort mit ihrer
rechtsextremen Agenda einzubrechen
glauben Sie denn dass es Grund gibt
Angst zu haben also es gibt Mitarbeiter
in der Verwaltung die vielleicht nicht
unter einem afd-landrat arbeiten wollen
es gibt Menschen die sind betroffen von
den bescheiden und schreiben die die
Kreisverwaltung rausschickt das sind
viele Daten viele sensible auch viele
sehr persönliche Sachen die jetzt
plötzlich in den Händen möglicherweise
einer Partei sind bei denen nicht jeder
nur im Sinne der Demokratie gut ist
damit will glauben Sie dass man damit
auch ein Klima der Angst vor Ort schafft
was es noch schwerer macht sich auch
dagegen zu stellen
ich kann diese
Ängste durchaus nachvollziehen da ist
sicherlich auch was dran ich möchte aber
an der Stelle auch dafür werben zu sagen
es ist in der in der Grundkonfiguration
eher ein exekutives ein administratives
Amt der Landrat ist an Gesetze und ein
Regeln gebunden er hat auch in gewisser
Weise politische Einflussmöglichkeiten
die sind aber wesentlich geringer als
die eines Ministerpräsidenten bei einer
Ministerpräsidentin wir haben aber in
der Vergangenheit auch gesehen in den
letzten Jahren gerade in Ostdeutschland
wie die AFD gegen zivilgesellschaftliche
Strukturen vorgegeben ist im
lebenspektrum aber auch zu Demokratie
Förderung was ihr ein Dorn im Auge war
und da immer wieder auch versucht hat
einen ähm eine Grundstimmung der Angst
zu sehen und insofern ist es glaube ich
ganz wichtig dass man jetzt an dieser
Stelle nicht mit dem Finger auf
Ostdeutschland zeigt und dort eben
diesen verbreiteten Rechtsextremismus
moniert sondern überlegt was kann man
tun um cd-gesellschaft dort zu stärken
lassen Sie uns bei dem Punkt
Ostdeutschland noch mal bleiben weil
auch dazu viele Kommentare kommen und
nächstes Jahr sind in drei ostdeutschen
Bundesländern auch Landtagswahlen ein
User schreibt die westdeutsche
Kolonialisierung des Ostens durch die
Treuhand hat für viel Unzufriedenheit
und wirtschaftliche Unsicherheit gesorgt
ist man da überrascht unabhängig davon
ob man das Wording so übernehmen möchte
oder nicht aber wie wie wie bewerten sie
das
es gibt ganz klar Unzufriedenheit im
Osten und ganz klar lässt sich sagen
dass diese Transformation nach 1990 auch
sicherlich viele Frakturen in der in der
Gesellschaft hinterlassen hat nur ist es
nicht so einfach das damit sozusagen der
die der Erfolg der AFD erklärt werden
kann da ist sicherlich auch bei dem ein
oder anderen
Protest ähm Stimmung da ist den anderen
etablierten Parteien zu zeigen und
bewusst in Kauf zu nehmen dass die AFD
gerade in Thüringen ja als gesichert
extremistische Partei gilt und andere
unter scheint auch der größere Teil zu
sein bewusst deswegen die AFD ähm wählen
also Transformation und die werden auch
eine Diskussionen Präsentation von
ostdeutschen in Führungspositionen in
der Politik in den Medien in der
Gesellschaft in der Kultur in der
Verwaltung im Gerichtswesen also überall
sehen wir dass es da repräsentationsl
ücken gibt und das ist sicherlich nicht
der Akzeptanz der Demokratie zuträglich
wenn die Menschen im Osten das Gefühl
haben dass ihre Leute dann irgendwann
irgendeiner Stelle an eine gläserne
Decke geraten
dann fragen wir uns zum Abschluss welche
Parteien denn jetzt besonders gefordert
sind dazu möchte ich gerne einen
kommentar von Sven Odendahl mit
einbinden der über Facebook gefragt hat
inwiefern ist die Profillosigkeit der
CDU unter Friedrich Merz ein Grund und
welche rechtskonservativen Angebote kann
man nicht Wählern machen die die AFD ja
momentan einfangen kann Nicole Diekmann
hat das gerade schon so ein bisschen
angesprochen in der Frage welche
Strategie wählt man da jetzt lassen Sie
uns bei der CDU bleiben inwiefern ist
die jetzt besonders gefragt
die CDU ist in der Tat besonders gefragt
und ich würde sagen da hat sie zuletzt
auch keine wirkliche gute Figur
abgegeben wie sie sich positioniert hat
gegenüber der AFD wir haben vorn von
Herrn Söder gehört der hat dazu gelernt
und sich und sagen da rhetorisch etwas
mehr zurückgehalten nicht die gleiche
Rhetorik zu verwenden wie man sie von
der AFD kennt jüngerer Vergangenheit
gesehen dass Friedrich Merz über seinen
offiziellen Twitter-Kanal doch Signale
ausgesendet hat beim Thema gender die
man unter Kultur Kampf zu mir kann die
ähm man doch sonst eher von AFD Personal
gewohnt ist und ich glaube das ist keine
für die CDU letztlich gute Strategie
weil sie damit zwiespältige Signale an
die eigene Mitgliedschaft an die
potenzielle wählerinnenschaft aussendet
und im Zweifelsfälle der Wähler die
Wählerin an er das Original denn eine
Kopie wählen wird also insofern würde
ich der CDU empfehlen klar bei der
Brandmauer bleiben klar be kennen was
sind die eigenen Punkte wo möchte sie
das Land hinführen und vor allem auch
nicht von der Idee der Volkspartei
verabschieden das heißt integrativ
Schichten übergreifend sich im
Parteiensystem aufzustellen
sagt der Politikwissenschaftler
Professor Benjamin Höhne von der
Universität Münster vielen Dank Herr
Professor Höhne dass sie heute im Stream
mit dabei waren sehr geehrter
und ich sage auch vielen herzlichen Dank
von uns hier vom ganzen Team von ZDF
heute live und das war's für heute zum
Thema der erste AFD Landrat in
Deutschland machen sie es gut danke fürs
kommentieren und Fragen bis zum nächsten
Mal tschüss